[MUSIC PLAYING]
TODD KERPELMAN: Hello, I/O Live.
Todd Kerpelman here,
and I am joined
by Leor Stern, who is product
operations lead for Wear OS
by Google.
Hi, Leor.
LEOR STERN: Hi, Tom.
Hi, I/O.
TODD KERPELMAN:
So I couldn't help
but notice there's quite a
number of watches around.
What's going on?
LEOR STERN: Yeah,
there are quite a few.
In fact, there are
29 watches here,
which represent a broad
spectrum of the watches
available today running Wear OS.
You can see some of the kind
of high-end, luxury-oriented
watches that we have here,
like the Hublot, which
is a limited edition watch.
You can see a good
sampling of fashion watches
from brands like
Michael Kors and Fossil.
And on your right
we have a bunch
of more fitness-oriented
watches, which
have features like GPS
and a heart rate monitor,
and are great to use when you
go out for a run or a workout.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Very cool.
And so, what is new
with Wear OS this year?
LEOR STERN: So what
we're looking at here,
behind us, are
these four displays,
which represent the four
product pillars of Wear OS, one
of which is the Assistant.
And we launched a new
UI for the Assistant.
It's actually rolling out
to watches now as we speak.
And then next to that is
the productivity pillar,
which is focused on
things like being
able to see when your
next appointment is
at a glance or a bunch of
new features for Google
Keep on Wear.
Next to that, we have the
connectivity and communication
pillar.
We're doing a lot of
work on notifications,
on making the watch
a great way for you
to be in touch with the people
and things that matter to you.
And then lastly,
the fitness pillar,
where we're also doing a
lot of work on Google Fit
and also focusing
on third party apps,
like Strava, like
Lifesum, that bring
a set of powerful
features to Wear OS users.
TODD KERPELMAN: Excellent.
Getting fit is always good.
So I know you had
mentioned that we
have some neat new
features that take
advantage of the Assistant.
Can we see a demo of that?
LEOR STERN: Yeah, absolutely.
So we've got a couple of
things at I/O this year
that are in developer preview.
We're previewing a new power
saver mode for the watch
where, once you dip below a
certain battery threshold,
will actually disable
a bunch of the radios
and different features to extend
the battery life of the watch
and make it easy for users to
get back to turning everything
on with a long press.
The other preview that we have
is Kotlin support for Wear OS.
And the big feature that we're
demoing here in the booth
is the new Assistant
UI for Wear,
for which we can segue to my
colleague Kangwon for a demo.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Let's go take a look right now.
Hey, Kangwon.
I hear there is a new
Assistant on Wear OS.
Can you show me what it does?
KANGWON LEE: Of course.
Now it has all the actions
available on the watch.
So let's see.
Do I need an umbrella tonight?
So it gives me the
weather information.
What's added is I can continue
this conversation using
suggestion tips or I ask
more questions, such as,
what about tomorrow?
These are called
suggestion tips that
are relevant to the context
and gives me more information.
These are first-party actions,
and I'm going to show you other
third-party actions because
Google knows about the weather
but not everything--
Google cannot turn on
the light on this one,
because this is
not Google product.
Would you tell it to
let there be light?
TODD KERPELMAN: All
right, I'll do that.
Let there be light.
KANGWON LEE: There you go.
TODD KERPELMAN: Whoa.
That's amazing.
KANGWON LEE: Yeah.
Pretty cool.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
Any other third-party
devices it can talk to?
KANGWON LEE: We actually have
a robot vacuum right behind me,
so let me try to start
cleaning this floor.
Start cleaning.
TODD KERPELMAN: Whoa.
Look at it go.
Go little robot vacuum, go.
KANGWON LEE: [INAUDIBLE]
TODD KERPELMAN: Get those chips.
Get them, get them, get them.
That is awesome.
And is there an action
that will make my kids put
their dishes away after dinner?
KANGWON LEE: You
can build your own.
That's the whole point.
You can have your own actions.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
That will be
available next year.
Wow.
That was fun.
All right.
So I have one last
question for you.
What time is it?
I'm just kidding.
My last question is,
if I'm a developer
and I want to find out more
about building something cool
on Wear OS, where would I go?
LEOR STERN: So now,
developers can build actions
on Google for the Assistant
and just keep the watch in mind
and make sure you
test it on watches.
And, of course, everyone
should come check us out
at wearos.google.com to
learn about the platform
and everything it has to offer.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
So there you go.
Actions on Google and
wearos.google.com.
And hey, did you
like this video?
Want to see something just like
it, or kind of close to it?
Head on over to g.co/io/guide
for more videos like this.
Thanks, everybody.
We'll see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]